STEVE: LAST AUGUST, BIDEN FACED
THE DISGUST OF THE WORLD AS WE
SAW THE BOTCHED WITHDRAWAL IN
AFGHANISTAN.
DESPERATE AFGHANS CLING TO
AIRCRAFT, FALLING TO THEIR
DEATHS.
INNOCENT FAMILIES STANDING WASTE
DEEP IN BLOODY SUPER WATER
PLEADING TO BE RESCUED.
WHO COULD FORGET THE SCENE OVER
THE DOVER AIR FORCE BASE OF 13
FLAG DRAPED COFFINS AS BIDEN
IMPATIENTLY CHECKED HIS WATCH
EVERY FEW MINUTES.
BY OCTOBER YOU COULD BARELY
FINDS A MENTION OF AFGHANISTAN
OR THE THOUSANDS OF OUR ALLIES
AND AMERICANS DROPPED BEHIND
ENEMY LINES.
SO THE NEWS TURNED TO DOMESTIC
CONCERNS.
THE INFLATION CRISIS HE CREATED.
THE BORDER CRISIS HE CREATED.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE AFGHAN
CRISIS WENT AWAY.
THE REAL RECUR CUSHIONS OF THE
BIDEN REGIMES INCOMPETENCE WERE
JUST BEGINNING.
IF THERE IS ONE STORY THAT
CAPTURES THIS.
IT'S THIS.
AN UTTERLY HORRIFYING REPORTS.
HERE ARE THE SHOCKING DETAILS.
THE SITUATION INSIDE AFGHANISTAN
HAS GONE THE SO DIRE SOME
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
SELL THEIR OWN CHILDREN JUST TO
BUY FOOD.
>> SINCE THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER
2 1/2 MONTHS AGO, ANY MONEY OR
ASSISTANCE HAS DRIED UP.
WITH 8 MOUTHS TO FEED, THIS
FATHER IS DOING THE UNTHINKABLE.
>> MY FATHER SOLD ME BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE BREAD, RICE AND
FLOUR, HE SOLD ME TO AN OLD MAN.
DIGGING HER HEELS INTO THE DIRT
SHE RESISTS.
BUT IT'S FUTILE.
STEVE REQUIRE MANY HARD TO
WATCH --
STEVE: IT'S HARD TO WATCH.
PARENTS SELLING THEIR DAUGHTERS.
IT'S HAPPENING ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
A 3-YEAR-OLD SOLD.
$550.
THIS IS WHAT BIDEN HAS DONE.
THIS APPALLING MAN MASQUERADING
AS A LEADER.
JUST BECAUSE HE WANTED TO MAKE A
SICK SPEECH.
WHEN HE DIDN'T END THE WAR HE
RESTARTED IT AS THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO ATTACKED US.
THE COUNTRY BECOMES A SAFE HAVEN
FOR TERRORISTS.
IN THE PROCESS OF PUSHING
THROUGH HIS SCHEME.
HE CREATED IN AFGHANISTAN A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS OF VAST
PROPORTIONS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT YEAR
VIRTUALLY THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
WILL BE ENGULFED IN ABJECT
POVERTY.
THERE ARE STILL U.S. CITIZENS
TRAPPED IN AFGHANISTAN.
GREEN CARDHOLDERS, THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT STILL
REFUSES TO RESCUE.
THE TALIBAN THEY HORSE AROUND ON
CARNIVAL RIDES AND PARADE THE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN MILITARY
EQUIPMENT BIDEN LEFT BEHIND
WHILE PARENTS ARE FORCED TO SELL
THEIR CHILDREN FOR FOOD.
PARENTS SELLING THEIR CHILDREN.
THAT'S WHAT BIDEN HAS DONE.
THE MOST UNIMAGINABLE CRUELTY
AND SUFFERING CAUSED BY BIDEN.
IS THAT WHAT HE MEANT BY THE
SOUL OF THE NATION CAUSING CHILD
SLAVERY.
IT